my english teacher in high school was  trying to fail me even though i had a  high grade in her class high school my  mom really did not care if i didn't go  to school so if i wanted to take a sick  day  she'd let me my english teacher was my  second period in order to be allowed to  practice i would have to get to school  before third period so you would always  catch me coming in at the end of second  period this made my english teacher not  like me very much you know fair reason  good enough but honestly i was good at  english so i didn't really have to come  that much to get a pretty decent grade  anyways my family goes on a trip to  florida and i have to miss a week of  school mom really didn't feel like  dealing with the school so she just told  them i was sick but she did not tell me  that i'm running out of time but like  for part two